in this video we're going to talk about
some terminology that we use to talk
about how circuits are put together in
previous videos we've talked about the
components or elements that are used to
make up circuits so for example resistor
capacitor and inductor our circuit
components we also call those elements
in addition we have some sources like a
voltage source or for example a current
source those would be the components or
elements of a circuit
LM mints now we're going to start
assembling these things into circuits
and we need a few more words to talk
about here's some circuit components
that are laying out on the tabletop and
we're going to connect those up with a
wire so for example I could connect this
one to this one with this yellow ideal
wire and an ideal wire has zero
resistance and it's perfect everywhere
and this forms a junction between these
two components and that is called a node
node is the word for junction meaning
the same thing that's what it that's
what it notice if I connect up these two
other components I still have one node
because I have one junction that's the
same voltage everywhere so that's what a
node is we're going to go over to this
circuit here and we'll identify the
nodes this is a little more
normal-looking
tiny circuit here's a junction right
here between a resistor and this voltage
source so that's one node if I move over
here I see resistors connected together
by ideal wires so that forms one single
node like that so that's our second node
and down below same sort of thing I see
the an ideal wire connecting the
resistors and the source so I can color
that in and that's node number three so
this circuit has three nodes now what's
connecting the nodes the thing that's
connecting the nodes is called a branch
and a branch is the same thing as an
element well count the the branches or
elements in this thing this voltage
source connects the third node to the
first node so that's one element this
resistor connects node 1 and node 2 so
that's the second branch this resistor
connects node 2 and node 3 so there's
the third branch and this resistor with
a separate current also connects those
two nodes so that's the fourth branch so
this this circuit has 1 2 3 4 elements
in it and it also means it has 4
branches
4 branches so that's what a branch in a
node are I would move the picture over a
little bit so that we can do this again
on a little more fancy circuit so first
thing we're going to do again just to
repeat the process we're going to count
the nodes here's a junction between a
resistor and a source here's three
resistors connected by a perfect wire so
that's the second node here we find
three more resistors connected by a
perfect wire there's third down here we
have there's a junction between two
resistors so that's our fourth node and
finally we have this node here
connecting these four elements with one
node this is sometimes called a
distributed a distributed node when it's
all spread out on the page like that but
it's still just one node so this circuit
has five nodes
and if we count up the elements that
tell us how many branches there are one
element two three four five six seven
seven elements
alright there's our two two keywords
elements and nodes now I'm going to
quickly move again down bring in another
circuit here we're going to talk about
the idea of a mesh and the other thing
we're going to talk about is the word
loop the word mass comes from screen
doors or screens that you put on on your
windows to keep the bugs out if I draw a
screen like this this is what it it
looks like bunch of crossing wires and
this little space right here that little
gap is called a mesh that's what that
word comes from so we're going to find
the meshes of our circuit and what we
look for here's the branches and the
mesh is a it is a kind of a loop that
fills up this open space this circuit
has one mesh two mesh
three meshes that's how that looks to
draw a mess you start on a node you go
through elements until you come back to
where you started that's how we did
those three and they fill the open
windows of the circuit so this circuit
has three meshes now that a mesh is a
loop and we can have other kinds of
loops too they don't have to be just the
ones that fill the fill the windows so
in general this circuit has other loops
and we'll identify some of those we
start let's just start at one of these
nodes here and go around like that and
this is a loop and I could draw their
loops in here
we'll make them all different colors
there's a loop if I start right here I
can draw a loop through these elements
and finally if I have a sharp eye
there's one more loop in this circuit if
I start let's just start right here and
it actually goes all the way around the
outside
so that's this circuit has three
actually if I add them together this has
three loops that I drew here plus the
three loops that were the messers so
this circuit has six loops circuits
always have a lot of loops and so
usually we don't talk about these more
often it's more organized and
straightforward to talk about how many
meshes are in a circuit alright so that
does it for this video we got mesh and
loop we talked about components and
elements
and we finished up with the idea also of
nodes and branches so that'll do it
there's our new vocabulary for talking
about circuits